bmw is bringing out the first ever bmw
2-series active tour it's a new niche
market vehicle to go with a host of
other special bmw series models
product manager stefan karch says bmw
isn't trying to cover every niche bmw
thinks the compact and subcompact
sectors have the most growth potential
over the next few years with the active
tour we hope to attract new customers to
the brands
a gondola as transportation to the
unveiling that's part of the active
tourist image as a car to have
adventures
in journalists seemed impressed by bmw's
latest model
says the car represents a novelty for
bmw basically it's a compact van a bit
longer than 4.3 meters
it's a front-wheel drive which is
something new for bmw and the motors
available are relatively small
there's a four cylinder and a three
cylinder which is especially economical
the car targets young families as well
as older customers for whom the three or
five series is a bit impractical who
want to sit higher up or who want to
have more room
we tested the four cylinder 110 kilowatt
diesel model
i disappear mountain climber stefan
glovach says the entire outboard sports
community consists of extremely mobile
people who take the liberty of going to
the mountains every weekend to pursue
their hobbies
but it's all a bit contradictory of
course outdoor sports enthusiasts want
to impact the environment as little as
possible
but on the other hand they get in their
cars every weekend and drive out to the
countryside
the active tour is built with
sustainability in mind and that's
attractive to the outdoor sports
community it's just as important as
interior space or safety it's a car
drivers can operate with a good
conscience
from the side the active tour is a
dynamic looking vehicle the l-shaped
back lights and wide wheels give the
2-series active tour a sporty appearance
despite its height
and the skirting is a real eye catcher
product manager frank niederlinda says
the car places a premium on comfort
drivers sit up high and the car is easy
to get into
it's all part of an optimal driver
orientation
the interior of the active tour is
spacious and functional as a car for a
variety of everyday needs
says that bmw tried to maximize space in
the back so it's easy to get into the
back seats of the car as well but the
vehicle is also variable the rear seat
can be moved back and forth which allows
for a lot of leg room
you can open the trunk with your foot
and it's easy to fold down the back
seats
cartester against miner says he thinks
that purists will have trouble with the
car because it's a front-wheel drive and
not a back wheel drive as is usual for
bmw plus it's not a six cylinder but he
also says that the market is very
diverse some people want more compact
cars in the premium sector and this bmw
is different in terms of its image from
anything else on the market with the
possible exception of the mercedes
b-class
the appointments go well beyond what's
usually offered in the segment miners
thinks the car will be a success
the bmw 2 series active tour retails
from twenty seven thousand two hundred
euros in
the aldenhofen germany center near the
western german city of
today we're looking at porsches lots of
porsches
15 variations of the classic 911
three mid-engine boxster roadsters
and three mid-engine cayman coupets
we're focusing on driving dynamics
porsche test driver eberhard ambrose
explains that driving dynamics means
handling agility and stability
when the driving dynamics are good he
says the vehicle responds directly to
all the driver's commands
that
says that top of the line sports cars
like porsche have a long tradition the
911 has been around since 1963 and the
boxster since 1996. both vehicles are
elite sports cars but they differ from
one another technically this 911 here is
a rear engine design while the boxster
is a middle engine design that means the
cars drive differently as we'll be
testing in aldenhofen
we take the rear engine 911 into a steep
curve
they're portioned close says the porsche
911 is the classic sports car its engine
has always bended back then come the
gears and then the driver that puts a
lot of weight on the car's rear axle the
advantage is when the car accelerates
the back wheels don't tend to spin as
much with a front or middle engine car
but it also means that when pushed to
the limit the car oversteers
that was a problem in the past 20 or 30
years in the meantime porsches have
excellent suspension and electronics
giving them the equilibrium of a middle
motor car
the 911 manages this curvy test course
without problems
says that the 911's handling is
unbelievably neutral because of the
suspension calibration the electronics
and the all-wheel drive when you hit the
gas you always have enough traction
the alden hoffen testing center atc for
short is part of the technical
university anakin which is known the
world round for its automotive prowess
now we're testing the middle engine
boxster's braking
says that people who have never driven a
race car should definitely get behind
the wheel of a boxster gts it's got 330
horsepower and top suspension and it
handles like a real sports car the
steering is very precise and the brakes
are unbelievably powerful you can stop
the car in a matter of meters without
losing control when you speed up again
the rear of the car swerves out a bit
but it's really easy to control
in designing the gts models porsche
engineers tried to make the driving
experience even more intense the boxster
gts combines race car performance with
everyday sportiness
klaus says that if you take a closer
look at the porsche boxster you see it's
a more modern sports car than the 911
here the motor is mounted directly
behind the driver and then comes the
transmission the same principle is used
in formula one cars and they're pretty
fast of course
the weight is concentrated in the middle
of the car this means the car is very
balanced in terms of weight and that's
comfortable for the driver when the car
is pushed to the limit
the most spectacular porsche is the 918
spyder with its multiple motors
this hybrid sports car is powered by a
4.6 liter conventional gasoline rear
wheel drive motor
in addition there are two electric
motors one driving the front axle
it's a new variation on all-wheel drive
that has the same sort of efficiency
hombres tells us that the all-wheel
drive improves traction and increases
speed on the straightaways it also makes
the car more stable in poor conditions
on the test driving circuit we push the
various models to the limit in a way
that's impossible in regular traffic and
all of them retain their excellent
handling even at top speeds that's a
mark of porsche excellence in research
and design
said twin is introducing the next
generation of the c1 since it was
introduced in 2005 the french car maker
has sold 780 000 c1s
the new version of the city runabout has
a redesigned front end and is available
in 3 and five door versions
low weight and the latest gasoline motor
technology mean that the c1 uses 3.8
liters of fuel per 100 kilometers
this autumn sees the revised version of
the ford focus hit the streets the front
end looks more luxurious than its
predecessor and the grill is reminiscent
of the top end model the focus st
the new focus comes in three diesel and
three conventional gasoline models all
of which promise energy efficiency the
interiors feature higher quality
materials and a touch screen instead of
a lot of buttons the basic focus retails
from sixteen thousand four hundred fifty
euros in germany
every three years volvo holds the ocean
race a spectacular sailing regatta
circumnavigating the globe this october
is the next start volvo is marking the
occasion by launching a special ocean
race edition for various existing volvo
models the design takes up the motifs of
wind waves and water today we'll look at
the xc60 in the ocean race design
so how does a maritime exterior fit a
suv designed for rough ground the xc60
may not be as sleek as a sailboat but
both are fairly robust on the nine
stages of the 39 000 mile regatta the
six sailing teams dock in 12 cities
between these destinations lies some of
the world's most demanding seas the
aquatic equivalent of off-road terrain
the ocean race designed for cars builds
on volvo's most basic equipment package
kinetic refining it with its own touches
like orange seams on the foot mats and
leather seats
the special edition costs an additional
3 200 euros but it means added comfort
like heated seats and an infotainment
system
the central console is subtly decorated
with the names of the cities that the
sailing teams head for on the nine-month
ocean race
the rear luggage cover not only screens
baggage from view it also presents the
regatta route on a map of the world by
the way the race ends in volvo's
hometown gtborg in june 2015.
one thing the xc60 has in common with a
sailboat is plenty of room for
provisions so the xc60 can set off well
prepared for a long voyage
says that along with all the little
details of the ocean race design
interior the xc60s panorama glass roof
can be opened to let in a bit of sea
breeze or mountain breeze for that
matter
the most conspicuous aspect of the
exterior is this exclusive shade of blue
silver mother of pear and metallic black
are also available
these light metal wheel rims are also
available exclusively with the ocean
race design
the engine has power too 350 newton
meters of torque ensure speed and
headwind or tailwind
wants to see whether her ocean race xc60
test car lives up to the race part it
has a t5 engine with
kilowatts the transmission is an 8 gear
automatic it shifts so promptly that you
always have optimal power
the 8 gear automatic can be put into s
mode so the gears shift even more
quickly and respond even more directly
to the gas pedal gear shift paddles on
the steering wheel enable the driver to
shift manually
on blacktop the xc60 launches from zero
to 100 kilometers an hour in 7.2 seconds
the car's top speed is 210 kilometers an
hour and it consumes only 6.7 liters of
fuel per 100 kilometers of course it
helps of a good tailwinds in your sails
our car tester ena says the interplay of
all the little design details gives the
ocean race edition its special charm she
especially likes the blue color which
takes up the ocean motif perfectly along
with the world map on the luggage cover
for a whiff of adventure
lexus has launched a compact class
hybrid a revised ct200h
it offers individuality luxury
technology and low fuel consumption
lexus says the 100 kilowatt engine burns
3.8 liters of super per 100 kilometers
but that figure can vary greatly
depending on the stretch driven
our car tester montesquiret says the
hybrid ct-200h's advantages are
especially apparent in the city and at
low speeds
that's when it shifts to the electric
engine using no gasoline at all but if
you drive on a rural road at a faster
speed than fuel consumption rises so
that you now have an average rate of 6.1
per 100 kilometers
that's still pretty low for a gasoline
engine but there are diesel models in
this segment that undercut it
so much for the engine in the interior
the driver faces an array of technology
mata says operating the infotainment
system with this joysticks takes some
getting used to but once you're
accustomed to it it works quite well the
car also has voice recognition and we'll
try that out now
the gps system's voice says the driver
should name an abbreviation menu after
the tone and that he can get assistance
by seeing help
says enter a destination
the gps repeats the command
and then asks for the name of a city it
explains at length how you can alter the
country name and begin a new search
breaks off the conversation he doesn't
have the patience for the system's
long-windedness though he concedes it
may be helpful for someone not used to
talking with a machine about operations
he doesn't understand
this way he'll learn all his options
the interior of the lexus is luxurious
the finest materials comfortable seats
and an instrument cluster that changes
its gauges to fit the driving mode but
the central console is initially
confusing
once again things take getting used to
says matas everything has been kept
relatively simple but all the technology
means lots of buttons matas thinks the
control knobs for the seat heating are a
bit odd
he's never seen them in another car
but once you accustom yourself to them
as with the infotainment system they're
ok
the lexus differs not only internally
but externally from other european car
makers compact offerings lexus designed
the ct-200h specifically for the
european market
says the ct-200h is very attractive for
those who love technology but the
compact segment is very competitive in
europe and how many people are this
fascinated with technology
high quality and workmanship is also a
criterion and many of lexus's european
competitors are just as good or even
better and so our car tester wonders
whether the ct200h will prevail on the
market over the long haul
the ct200h's high starting price of 27
600 euros will make it hard for lexus to
grab market shares from vw golf and the
others in this class
but for a compact hybrid the price is
decent and the selection of compact
hybrids is still very limited in europe
someone looking for one could soon find
himself getting into the lexus
if there's an epitome of the classic car
then it's this two-seater together with
the chevrolet corvette the 1955 ford
thunderbird is the american sports car
manuela feist is a fan of a classic
american automobiles and especially her
55 t-bird she loves the way it looks but
she also appreciates its performance
the first generation t-birds had 200
horsepower by comparison porsches built
at the time only had 70.
manuela says she's fascinated by the v8
american cars of the 1950s because they
have a lot of displacement and power
that gives them their typical blub blub
engine sound
her interest in automobiles is no
coincidence her father was a car dealer
she grew up on chrome and oil and
discovered her passion for cars at an
early age
manuela tells us that even as a little
girl she played with the mechanics and
the cars her father taught her how to
drive off-road of course as soon as her
legs were long enough to reach the
pedals she's always been a car
enthusiast she was born with gasoline in
her blood
the t-bird was a hit from the moment it
appeared in showrooms marilyn monroe
rode through the united states in the
sports car on her honeymoon
the model remains the most coveted
because of its purest design as of 1958
the t-bird became a four-seater and lost
much of its charm
even in golden rod yellow the car
doesn't look overly ostentatious that's
part of its appeal
manuela tells us that people wave and
applaud when she drives by
vintage cars she says put people in a
good mood they like a bright yellow
vintage car with lots of chrome that
sounds good
she says she's never experienced
anything negative in her thunderbirds
the 1955 t-bird was surprisingly
affordable aficionados call it the early
bird and say it's the loveliest of the
11 generations of the model
its size is modest for a u.s car of its
era and it fits in a standard european
garage
people began collecting t-birds over 30
years ago and fans have always been able
to get spare parts if its mileage
weren't so poor 20 liters per 100
kilometers the roadster could still be
considered a relatively practical
everyday car its technology is simple
and reliable
manuela is even able to do some of the
repair work herself
she tells us how she's fixed her car she
photographed the motor and then enlarged
the print one day when the engine
wouldn't run she compared it with the
photo and identified what was wrong
she then repaired the motor
the t-bird packs a muscular v8 engine
under the hood
competing models from the time like the
jaguar xk-140 only had six cylinder
motors
with 4.8 liters of displacement the
engine delivered around 200 horsepower
to the ford-o-matic three-speed
automatic transmission
other cars have since bested the t-birds
performance but none have ever matched
its sound
first generation t-birds are growing
rare the technology was robust but the
exterior was prone to rust and not all
of them were driven only in good weather
a decently preserved early bird is worth
around 45 000 euros
you